do a Google search for Callao jerkwads
what do you find Google itself we told
you how thousands of their employees
signed a letter protesting Google's work
with project maven an effort to make our
drones more precise so civilian lives
are spared it's a good thing now Google
has pulled out of the project under
pressure from those workers apparently
doing anything connected to our military
which protects the lives of those same
pasty workers at Google
it's just bad for their brand but Google
you know it's bad for your brand you
your motto used to be don't be evil but
isn't what you just did kind of the
opposite and yet while deciding not to
help our military with their AI you
invest fortunes in other countries AI
what do you think they're gonna do with
that
d-day being yesterday that's the
opposite of good timing now I'm not
gonna call you traitorous you're just
scared you're scared cuz in this day and
age among your peers helping Uncle Sam
is helping the oppressor oh you love the
wealth but now dismiss those who enable
and protect it how removed you become
from the ideas your parents and their
parents and their parents fought for the
decision Google made is one of course
that they can make but it's foolish and
harmful as drones become an inevitable
part of our defenses and our enemies
offenses Google made a choice maybe we
should do the same
day and it drives me crazy there's it's
hard to like you can't just say I'm no
longer using Google right because then
all of a sudden I'm going to Google
other options and Bing Bing this being
still work I don't know I use Ask Jeeves
I use Alta Vista Digital you know and
Google is such it's such a huge company
it's not just a search engine yeah and
what's interesting about this is that
Eric Schmidt the former CEO he is on the
Defense Intelligence you wouldn't even
he would have stuck with it but because
he's very concerned about especially
with China for example and technological
innovations and what it could do to our
future and if you want to be safe and
protected in America then you should
probably help our military this is what
get cuz I Smits no longer there correct
if he would and they're selling stuff to
China or they're working with China
Google right
I'm afraid to criticize Google because
it might leak my search history and then
I'm toast I will say it's a weasel move
because you're helping the country
offensively because you reduce civilian
casualties yeah and then defensively
because the terrorists are getting
access to drone technology so you want
to defend against that America in a sick
way is almost too safe remember world
war one world war two the threats were
everywhere we had domestic attacks
people were getting shipped overseas to
fight for our country we're so far
removed from that we don't have the
sense of patriotism and nationalism that
we used to we can afford to you know let
these things slide and not protect the
nation like it used to be protected we
need to be more worried about clear and
present dangers what your something in
terms of an imminent threat or actually
more on high alert about something to
say you know what we really do want to
do whatever it takes to keep ourselves
safe like after 9/11 when people had
that yeah they had the wherewithal to be
able to say you know what I'm open to
this cuz I want to make sure that this
does not happen again so then there runs
the risk of times you know passing and
become a little bit complacent or you
feel a little bit too safe right you
wake up call them what it's obviously
they're pro-business we talk about
businesses can do whatever they want the
NFL can do what they want Google can do
what they want but the nature of this
technology by its very precision is
designed to reduce collateral damage so
what could be their argument other than
they want to appear PC and not be seen
working with I'm sort of surprised at
your reaction to this because if I told
you that I was going to invent something
allowed for constant surveillance by
artificial intelligence I think
generally Greg would say not as well I
don't worry that yeah surveilling me I'd
have drones in my house if I could know
that right already
little grown man little
yeah you don't want to see you get mad
at okay but I'm just saying when you
think about the idea that you are
empowering drones to have the kind of
facial recognition body nation record
you think wait a second where is privacy
where are my rights where am I
protections as an individual so you can
say oh what this is make our drones more
effective but I think then it starts
really how would you say escalating and
the bad guys get it and then suddenly
we're in trouble too I don't that's why
I think so you asked me because I'm
about military well if it's about
military I'm on your side because I want
our military to be strong but I don't
think that everything should be in the
military's hands Greg I don't think that
the only thing is it's good to be in
somebody else's military they don't have
that they will employee to the cave am i
right
there's no Google in caves I don't even
know what that means there's no Wi-Fi in
caves there's a bumper sticker or a
t-shirt